this is a production of cornell
university
i'm so happy y'all are here like five
minutes ago before you all walked in the
room was empty i was like well i'll
still go first i'll get to present to an
empty room but um anyway it's lovely to
see all of you and those of you on zoom
it's nice to see you too
um so
i'm not actually gonna be talking to you
about an experimental learning program
although we are experimenting a little
bit but more of an experiential learning
program that's called
learning by leading and
i want to give you a little context
before i jump right into what this
program is
and start first with um that it it comes
from a place a very purposeful place at
the botanic gardens we
launched a strategic plan in 2018 and
we've been working from it since then
and
at that time we also crafted a new
mission which
probably can't read this tagline here
but
connecting people's implants for a world
of beauty diversity and hope and so the
premise behind this is that we have bio
biological diversity and we have
cultural diversity and those two things
are
intricately connected and dependent on
each other and we want to elevate that
and share those different stories
and how they come together and to do
that we have these three goals that we
we focus on all the time as we're
thinking about how we do things
and those goals are to grow we do that
through all the gardens that we have
through the natural areas that we have
and we want to do that in a sustainable
fashion
we have lots of programs and we want to
inspire people whether it's through the
programs or it's through those
landscapes to really foster that
connection between plants and people but
also to steward the next generation
and we want to connect people want to
connect people to plants but we also
want to connect with this university and
the wealth of resources that are here
the intellectual resources
both here within our community and
beyond so those are the three ways that
we think about how we do everything that
we do and the more that we can do
something that hits on all of those
goals the better so
we've been working with students for a
long time since as long as i've been
here and
we have um an intern program had an
intern program that was very successful
and we dabbled with other kinds of
student learning programs but what we
really wanted to do is to
bring
find something that would capture
and allow us to do all of these things
and so when we were thinking about this
after shortly after launching the
strategic goal i was at
an american public garden association
workshop for university botanic gardens
and we were talking we were the workshop
was about how do you work with students
how do you engage with students how do
you get them to come to your programs
how do you teach with them what are the
challenges what are the opportunities
and it was a really fruitful discussion
and out of that i
met some colleagues from the university
of california davis
and they presented this program called
learning by leading and
it was a program that they started 15
years prior and
they were in a position similar to us
where they were their resources were
dwindling the university's budget model
was changing and
they were really keen to work with
students and faculty and so they started
this program and they'd had
at the point that we read this workshop
tremendous success with it not only in
engaging with students which was their
primary goal but in
really transforming their organization
and transforming the students that went
through the program and then they
started talking about how they start
we're transforming the university itself
and we were like whoa
this is too good to be true and we
watched what they did and we
learned about it they invited us out to
a workshop and so we went um at davis to
meet with some of the students
that i have pictures of here today and
talked with them and really learned a
lot about it and we said we can do this
we should do this and we brought it back
and over the last um so that was in 2018
2019 we've we've started crafting this
and we did some pilot programming of it
in 2019 and then kovit came along in
2020 when we were just about to launch
it full bore and
so we just took a little step back but
i'm today i'm here to share some good
news about it and before i do that
i want to talk to you about how this
program works how it's a little
philosophically different than some of
the other programs that we've had before
and it starts with the power of place so
we are here on this tremendously
beautiful campus
with like right now as everybody's aware
it's just really incredible but it's
incredible year year-round and there's
lots of opportunities for place-based
education
to make meaning
to showcase the expertise that's here
whether it's through research whether
through teaching or just the kinds of
experiences that students can have here
and it's a really really great place for
co-creation and to
do things in the landscape that students
have ownership of so it's one of the
and here at the whoops
wrong button
here to this is the herb garden and we
we think this is a great place students
have told us it's a great place to learn
they come all the time probably to this
place one of the things that the
um
the landscape architect at the
university of california davis was
telling us that this workshop we went to
is that
people remember two landscapes in their
lifetime
one is the childhood landscape that they
grew up in and the meaning that it has
for them and the second one
is the place that they went to college
so this
has even more meaning because of the
of the space that you all are learning
students are learning and so we really
wanted to take advantage of that and
build upon that
so i took this picture on saturday some
of our teams had a program where they
were having a plant sale and they were
doing crafts and just inviting people in
the community to celebrate spring and i
put this up here because i wanted to
focus in on this little sign right here
which you can't read right now
but
there it is
and
this was made by the students the teams
and i didn't have anything to do with
this event but here is the pro this is
the whole program in a nutshell it's
creating a new generation of
environmental leaders through
stewardship co-creation and sense of
place so i was really proud i was like
oh look at that right about there they
did it themselves and
so they are eating and living and
breathing and modeling this program for
us
so
um
with this program i was just not another
tenant of it says power of place is
really important but the other part is
is how students learn and so at cornell
botanic gardens we occupy a lot of the
place that is cornell so
i think on campus we manage and steward
600 acres of the university's campus so
fully one-third of the college of this
campus is maintained and stewarded by
cornell botanic gardens so
we know that students are out there in
our landscapes whether they're there
with their classes and some of the
faculty we know are bringing students
there
we know that they use it recreationally
we're trying to encourage that
but we're always looking to share
find ways to share that living
laboratory with students and the other
thing that we have in addition to
occupying the space is we have these
really incredible staff with lots and
lots of expertise and knowledge and we
want to share that and the way that they
take the knowledge some of which they've
learned here
as being graduates of this program and
of cornell and
wanted to put students in touch with
them to learn from them and
to move beyond a space where they're
just learning the whole time right but
they're experiencing they're getting to
do the real work and they're progressing
through
um
a leadership letter which i'll show
share with you in a minute
and so elevating leadership
as this as the name implies is something
that's really important it's another key
tenant of the program
and we know that students no longer just
need a mastery of a single subject
matter right you have to they have to
be masters of lots of things and not
just subject but you're going to be
working in non-routine places
you have to be technical creative
interactive there's going to be
competition
right and
know how to work in teams know how to
lead a team what does that mean so
we are at cornell there's a full system
of lots of learning opportunities
cornell botanic gardens is a fully
functioning non-profit organization that
has all the red tape that comes with an
organization it has all the headaches
all the challenges but what we try to do
with this program is turn that around
and look at it and present it to
students pull back the curtain and bring
them along with those headaches and that
red tape and all the good stuff too but
really to to give students an experience
of working in the real world
and um
part of what this
does in having this organization sponsor
this program and bring students in
behind the curtain is also to provide
that safety net right so if something
goes wrong it's okay
in fact we embrace that and we say
that's this is a great learning
opportunity why didn't this go the way
we wanted it to or why
did we have a misstep here and and even
if somebody would call it a failure i
don't ever
try not to use that word but even in
something that would maybe be deemed a
failure is to look at it as an
opportunity to do it to learn from it
what went wrong why didn't it succeed
and how do we do it again differently
next time
so
just want to share with you the
framework of the model and talk a little
bit about how we're using it so
there are
um
so when davis presented this to us they
were talking about how most students in
an internship program are at this first
step one and step two where they are
primarily learning and participating
and
they don't often get steps three and
four where they get to lead projects or
they even get to mentor other students
in projects
so
the premise of this program is to move
students from steps one and two up into
the steps three and four and beyond as
quickly as possible
and so
you'll hear me talk about here in a
minute
so we have team members who come on into
the program and they're usually
participating and learning at steps one
and two they come in they work with us
for a few hours they're learning some of
the
expert sub the subject matter expert
topic and then they're participating
with us but then
we want them to move into the leadership
component of the program and to do that
quickly pop as possible whether it's as
a leader of the team or as a leader of a
project
and
students even if they're not in a
leadership position that way they take
on a leadership role in some of the
projects they work on
and then mentoring others and how to do
that
and then what we're
slowly getting to now that we've um
gotten past the covid pause is to be
moving students into even further up the
model where they are able to take on do
a deep dive into a program or an area
and do a signature project and even
apprentice with us either as a student
worker in a paid capacity or perhaps
even after they graduate and come work
with us or at another
organization
in that capacity
so our teams look like this we have a
staff mentor so we have i mentioned all
the staff expertise that we have
and
we have quite a bit of it at the gardens
and so we have
for each mentor they have to have a
subject matter expertise they need to be
able to work with students
and they need to have the capacity to to
be a mentor and some of that
we know some of the staff that we have
and who can do this and some of that we
provide training for that
so every team has a staff mentor
each team has two student student
leaders and this is a paid student
um
right here it says that they're paid
five for five to ten hours a week that's
during the academic year so the fall in
the spring semester
and then um they have to do at least one
but up to two summers with us where they
work with us full time
and so they they become the team leaders
and we
we have two so that they can balance
they can both balance their strengths
but they also balance the work and take
on different parts of what it takes to
lead a team
and then we can have anywhere from five
to ten to fifteen team members who are
students who presently are doing this in
a volunteer capacity but i just had a
great conversation with marvin last week
about how we might look at this in a
for credit capacity so that there's some
incentive beyond just wanting to learn
the material
so this is what a team looks like
and
the things that they're doing in this
team and they're doing this through
through the work that they're doing
through the experiences that they're
getting but also through some of the
training that we give them so there's
some focus area and content and i'll
talk about that as it relates to the
teams that they're on
we bring in leadership theory and
practice so we we draw upon that talked
about connecting with the university we
have a wealth of
resources here especially in mentoring
students and
peer-to-peer counseling and leadership
and so
we have
brought in students from i think it's
student life and they came and they did
the clifton strengths finder so
as as we are all
blessed with lots of strengths um
and there's like 30 or 40 of them that
they that the gallup has identified and
this model says you know these are the
10 that you have you are really really
strong in bring those to the table and
then the next person they bring their
tent to the table and the next person
they bring then their ten to the table
and
when you have a full suite of all of
those strengths and you bring them all
to the table and you play to your
strengths it makes for a really
collaborative and a really dynamic team
so we did training on that
talk a lot about collaboration there's
so much collaboration whether it's
within the organization or within on
campus within even the teams themselves
and
always talking about communicating
how do you do it well what happens if it
doesn't go well what if you don't
communicate at all and and
um really trying to model that for them
and and coach them and guide them
through that as well as team building
and mentoring and decision making and
the very last one on here is probably
the most important one which is
co-creation and that's an opportunity
for
students to
when i was talking about pulling back
the curtains and going through all the
steps of work
and doing it we invite them to the table
and we it's not that we assign them
programs or projects to work on say here
are some parameters you have an
opportunity to do
something
what do you want to do with it so i'll
give you a more concrete example which
is
with our education team we say we have
an event coming up it's for the public
and we need you to come up with hands-on
activities
around at this garden but what kind of
activities you do what kind of hands-on
things you want to do what kind of
information you want to share whatever
the topic is who's working on it that's
all for you to work out amongst
yourselves
and this is a this is an opportunity
where students can take a leadership
role in saying well i want to do this
and i'll get do the research and then
i'll share it with all of you or
somebody will get the materials or
in that capacity
so we have three teams
and
i'll tell you
more in depth about each one of them we
have one it's called the garden
ambassadors and this is our education
and outreach team
we have a sustainable landscape team and
they're working
trying to develop sustainable landscapes
both at the garden and across campus
and we call horticulture enterprise
which is focused on growing plants for
sale whether it's for a plant sale or
it's to sell to
back to the gardens to
for a garden or for a garden on campus
and the slides i'm about to show you are
not mine they were created by the
students in the teams themselves
we asked them to present about their
teams who they are what they're doing
for an advisory council meeting that we
had with our advisors and so just don't
want to take credit for their work
so this is our first team this is our
garden ambassador team and
our staff mentor there is kevin moss
who's our student and public engagement
coordinator and he works with jakarta
zellner who's an arts and sciences major
um and uh nola red meyer and so nola has
been with us two years and jakarta has
been with us one year staying on for two
and we received an engaged cornell grant
to launch this team to do community work
in the community work on campus
they have a team of five
and
what they're doing
is
outreach visitor education informal
education they're doing a lot of it at
the gardens
this is our first team and this was the
one that we were
going to go out into the community and
do lots of work and that's when kova hit
so
part of the reason they're a small team
and part of the reason that we shifted
focus this is one of those learning
opportunities is how do you do a an
outreach
ambassadorial team
all online
right
so
that was that was one of the shifts and
we start we're like well okay i guess we
really are going to learn by leading and
do this this is a real opportunity to
learn and they really did they did a
great job and they
did a lot of programming online they met
online and they figured out how to do
team building online and all through
zoom and
all of the
the really interesting
challenges that that presented there was
an opportunity in every one of them
so their first in-person event was in
last august they hosted an open house
for the community and
they
got to
figure out all aspects of it each team
member took on a different part and led
in developing activities
and then
we find that students are really
interested in herbs and this group was
no exception but it's ripe with lots of
biological information and growing
information but also very very rich in
cultural
connections so the first thing they did
was develop
a webinar so this is kevin moss he's the
mentor and he
hosts a monthly webinar series called
burden views and so he invited jakara
and nola to present a webinar and they
did so on lavender and presented all the
cultural stories about this and did all
the research around it
and
cooking and recipes and all kinds of
things with it
then they developed an in-person tour
based in the herb garden around all the
cultural stories that exist exists
around a lot of those herbs
and then they one of the other things
they did is created this discovery
station where um
a little more hands-on and got to
scratch and sniff all the herbs and take
some away with you and make potions and
make sachets and all kinds of things so
it was a lot of fun and this is where
we sort of step back
heaven as a mentor shares his knowledge
of how you deliver and develop
educational programs and what you need
to think about and shares that but then
all steps back and and just sort of
guides the process
one of their other um
really successful events was in the fall
there was an orientation event that we
hosted right as students were coming
back and we partnered with don in the
nature rx program and invited lots um as
many uh
environmental nature-based organizations
on campus that were interested in
partnering with us and there were quite
a few and we invited them to come down
to this open house event that we had on
a wednesday morning and they had a great
turnout lots and lots of students came
down many came with their parents some
came just by themselves
they were they set up all the tents they
figured out how many they needed how
many tables coordinated with all those
different groups to come down
we had the raptor group there an
orienteering group and the
group the hiking club was there
and selling their used material and
telling students where they could come
and get more
and we had that competition we talked
about so one of our teams is a
horticulture enterprise team starting up
wanting to do plant sales but we also
have another group called quartus form
that does the same thing
and what we're trying to do with that is
to to present different options so but
also what do you do when you have two
clubs that are trying to do the same
thing and so looking at pricing and
looking at having variety and what the
selection is and really partnering more
and more so that's something that's a
goal that the team has had for a long
time
is to figure that out
and then they had a gratitude project
where they invite visitors to come into
this is a willing hut that was created
by the art of horticulture and we invite
visitors to come in and say what they're
grateful for about plants and nature and
gardens and to leave a
nice little tag there and it's an
ephemeral art project so it's just
growing again and these tags are down
there this is the pounder vegetable
garden which is across from the welcome
evan welcome center so i invite you all
to come down and all of you
um
and
they also have this garden stories where
they interview different people
associated with the gardens or different
people and what their connection with
plants is and gardens and tell their
story through what a blog entry so this
is another student who's not one of our
co-leaders but one of our team members
and this was
a project that she's taking leadership
on
and then they started off they learned
the importance of social media and if
you're going to have events you need to
get people to them so what's the best
way to do that and we know from
experience that instagram is probably
one of the best ways to reach students
and even locals in our community and so
they
went worked with our communications team
on
what do you need to do to create an
instagram account and how do you make it
successful and what kinds of posts you
put on there and how frequent and all of
those great questions
so our other team is our sustainable
landscape team this is led by students
daniel sausaver in environment and
sustainability sciences and coco dawkins
who's also an environment in
sustainability major and they're
mentored by christy boyce who's our
natural areas gardener and very
knowledgeable in natural areas
restoration native plant ecology and
she's been working very closely with
them
they have a pretty robust team so up to
nine students
10 students i think working with them
and come out often on the weekends to do
restoration and natural area
naturalistic gardening projects
and
their goals and i don't mean to read all
this a lot of words there but really
working with the staff the horticulture
and the natural area staff at our
gardens to learn about what is a
sustainable landscape what role do
native plants play in that
how do we
help the gardens and the university work
toward its sustainability goals through
a landscape
and doing that primarily through native
plant and naturalistic gardening as well
as habitat horticulture
so
they're when they first come on they
have to do a lot of learning primarily
plant identification right so what's a
native plant what's a non-native plant
what's an invasive what's the difference
between all those three things
um what's the importance ecological
importance of a native plant
in a sustainable landscape and what's
why do we care about invasive species
invasive plants or invasive pests and
what role do they have
and
so daniel created this slide and he was
talking about it with our advisory
council because once he got trained in
all this plant identification his job
was to teach the team members as they
came on and all the plant identification
and all of these important parts
and so then they get out and they use
all that knowledge and they this is one
of the areas they did a restoration of
this was a beautiful overlook in the
mindy wildflower garden overlooking fall
creek which would be phenomenal today so
it'd be nice and cool and shady
but it was overgrown with lots of
invasives so they learned
how you remove those and then now
they're replanting it with
natives that are low growing and don't
need a lot of especially this time of
year when it's very dry a lot of water
they do a lot of plant collectings
primarily seed collecting and learn how
do you collect seeds what time of year
how do you clean them so this is the
progression from collecting to cleaning
them to looking at them they look at all
of them under a microscope to make sure
they're viable and they don't have any
hitchhikers along the way
and then they grow all those seeds out
and they learn how to grow them from
seed as well as propagate other native
plants that they then grow out in our
nursery facility and then take to um
put out into the ground for a planting
like this where they're trying to remove
some of this non-native lawn and
create a more naturalistic sustainable
landscape there
and then one project they're
particularly excited about is
their
this is a shrub restoration area so
i'm sure many of you are aware of the
loss of all the ash trees in our
community due to the emerald ash borer
and so this is a space where we had to
take down close to 20 trees so the tree
canopy has completely changed um in this
landscape so and with that comes the
threat of invasive species coming in so
they are now replanting it with
native shrubs both to talk about the
importance of repopulating it with
natives but also to put as a
demonstration of what what native shrubs
work really well in this area and can
support wildlife and pollinators here
then our final team is our horticulture
enterprise team and this is vincent
capleoni she's graduating from plant
science this semester and hillary
mulford who is a landscape architecture
major
and their
mentor is missy bidwell who's our
greenhouse manager and very skilled and
expert in plant scheduling she's been
doing it for the gardens for years to
make sure that we get all the plants
that we need
growing and to go out into the gardens
so that they
get planted after our last frost date
they too have a very robust team of
like about 10 or 11 students who come
out and regularly work in the greenhouse
with them
to do things like plant propagation
plant scheduling they're learning about
integrated pest management plant health
care
they're learning about how to schedule
those plants what plants they have to
get in at what level to get to a plant
sale
and then
how to see that full cycle through so
whether the plants are going into our
collections or they're going out for
sale how do you make sure that they get
through that whole
whole schedule
so
they too um spent a lot of time learning
in our nursery and in our greenhouse
like how do those systems work how do
they um
what what is required in them and some
of them have started from not knowing
anything they've come not from plant
science but from further
major further afield and so it's all
very new so learning how to work in that
environment is very important
this is a picture of their first and i
want to say plant sale and i am doing
this purposely because
one of the things that we thought was a
failure on our staff part was we had
we're like this great idea to have an
enterprise team but what we failed to do
was to get them a means by which they
could enterprise that is we didn't have
a an operating credit card sale system
for them when the team started
and so we were hemming and hawing and
feeling really bad about that and then
we said we
embraced the model right pull back the
curtain and you come with us through the
red tape and through all the processes
with the cornell's business center to
learn what it takes to get a credit card
system going and what all the steps you
have to take to keep it safe and take
all the training to be compliant in
those systems and they went through it
from start to finish
and now they have it
and they were really successful at that
last plant sale they did it by donations
and they actually i think earned 700
just by offering it as donations so that
was they felt really happy about that
but they also recognized you know they
learn things like what do you need to be
able to take in even donations and how
they process that
um their first sale was what they called
the big red plant sale
and they wanted to buy
and produce mums red and white mums to
be ready for homecoming weekend and so
they ordered those little plugs and then
they grew them out and they had them for
sale
and figured out how to do all that get
it timed just right
and how they worked their credit card
system now that it was in place and how
many people they needed where and when
and how to bring all this out there
and then the other type of program that
they are working with is
some of the partnerships we have with
faculty and residents whether it's on
north campus or west campus and this one
happened to be on north campus and we
were invited by a faculty in residence
there to participate in a wellness
program
and
we
they came up with this succulent plant
talked about the importance of plants as
as a wellness and having one in your
room is really important you can't get
outside or just looking at it so they
did a plant propagation work work
workshop at in the dorms and um you know
they had planned for 50 and we
encouraged them to think you know you
have 50 signed up but you probably have
more come in so they
they heeded our
advice and it's a good thing because
they had 150 come through that they
counted
so um
they started just propagating little
just you know with plants you can take
one little um one little leaf in in this
way
and one of the things that i heard them
talk about just recently to our advisory
council is one of the things they learn
pretty quickly on is
you don't can't just learn about the
plants that you're selling you have to
be prepared to talk about especially
with house plants every kind of house
plants because in this environment they
had students bringing their plants down
to them saying what's wrong with this it
won't grow
so
and then asking them a whole suite of
other questions so it was a great
i'm not sure we could have prepared them
for that so that was great
so our future plans and um
we have lots of them we still have three
teams we're going to stick with the
three teams for the foreseeable future
but we have lots of other teams that you
know
basically
mirror the parts of our organization
so our fundraising fundraiser would love
to have a team and we know students are
interested in learning how to fundraise
um if they're going to go into a
non-profit organization
we have other horticulture teams that
we'd like to have design teams other
education programs working with our
youth programs and all of that so that's
we see that on the horizon is coming
we're going to get another year under
our belt with this
with these teams and do some more
one of the other things that we're
really paying attention to is what
students need from the program in
addition to the things that i've talked
about
one is course credit so
looking at opportunities for that and
the other thing is collaborations
outside of our organization so as much
expertise as we have we want to build on
the expertise that's here on campus and
do some collaborations and i just want
to share two quick ones with you
and the first of those is a partnership
that we have with the university's
landscape architecture this architect
this is david cutter here in the um
he's the university's landscape
architect and he was approached by
we were both approached by
alumni affairs and development to create
a medicinal garden in front of cornell
health
and
so we both thought there were there's
ways that we could collaborate on
bringing this to
fruition and this picture is
um
of
the spreadsheet is one that daniel
saucer on our sustainable team put
together of all the plants that are
native and have sustainable features and
then
what their growing requirements are but
also what their medicinal qualities are
and then because he's working at our
organization what all the cultural
connections are so it's a really
tremendous resource that we will use
from a lot longer than this project
and then in the red and
orange tan shirt there is hillary i
mentioned is a landscape architect so
david is a tremendous collaborator with
us and he invited
all of our students on and has given her
the opportunity to use her skills in
landscape architecture and design the
project with him
and she said to him i would not have
gotten this opportunity in any other way
so here is their plan so in the top
of the screen is their sketch
scoping out you know what the garden is
there's their list of plants that
they're going to put in how they're
going to put them together and then this
is hillary's rendering of what the
spaces
we hope will look like
maybe not right after planting but
within a year or two afterwards so
and that's scheduled to go in
next month
and
the enterprise team and the sustainable
landscape team they're growing up many
of the plants are going to go into these
gardens
so that's they're getting experience
there the other
project that our teams have taken on and
it's really important to them is
they want to connect and honor all of
the students on campus and they want to
put out a planting
that says black lives matter on the
front of our lawn in front of the nevin
welcome center and they wanted to figure
out how to do this and they approached
us with the idea and
you know we talked a lot about how
whether we should it should be planted
in the ground or it needed to be some
other kind of media and what they landed
on was a
planting that was similar to one that a
student justin conrad did years ago
where he
put bulbs in all of these pots and um
figured out how many bulbs that were
needed how many pots are needed
how big of a space is needed where do we
get this material what is it going to
cost and
working with bill miller on trying to
source that the daffodils for this
project
he's also offered green
cooler space to be able to
cool them
um after we purchase them
the other part of this that their teams
are taking on working with
some of the campus groups that we worked
with a year ago when we brought carolyn
finney here to talk about her book
blackface's white spaces
do better cornell black students united
and some of the other campus groups and
community groups where
to offer this invitation to participate
to have the bulbs after the planting is
done and it's bloomed and
this is the rendering that they have
what it's planned to look like this
would be next spring
they also we also just
had a chance to write a grant to get
hopefully get funds to support this so
they were able to see that process go
through
and so i'll end with uh just a note
about our impact that what we see is
happening what we hope is happening and
i can tie it back to what i've asked
students to give me in a formal way in
terms of a reflection but also what i've
heard them say to
others about the program is that it is
doing that grow right that goal that we
have of growing and providing
experiential learning both in our
landscapes about our landscapes but also
them personally
with those real world experiences it's
inspiring it's inspiring them in terms
of what projects they want to bring in
and do for us inspiring us
part of what we love about this program
is
you all are teaching
and giving them new knowledge and they
get to bring that back to us and we get
to learn from them so it is a two-way
street and it's
really inspiring for us but it's and as
that knowledge sharing is happening it's
um it's very contagious that co-creation
is part of that inspirational piece of
this
and then the connection these
collaborations that we're trying to have
whether it's other parts of campus or
it's in our community or it's out into
the world
that's really important to us to grow
for that so i'll leave you with these
beautiful faces
and um
hope that
i've shared with you a program that what
i
want to leave you with is an invitation
to think about if there's a connection
for you with this program with us
we're looking for collaborators we're
looking for partners where whether it's
to connect us with the students who may
be interested in this or to offer
opportunities for the teams themselves
and with that
just ask you if you have any questions
or comments or suggestions
[Applause]
i'm intrigued with the medicinal plants
in front of the health center
so it's one thing to have in there and
look at them and say this is used for
that or but is there any
plans let me actually use them or
encourage some use or is it going to be
strictly hands off
because you know there's a problem with
self-medicating self-medicating dosage
and things like that so right that's why
i'm intrigued by
thinking this through
okay
you don't have to talk a little bit
offline just about the name of the
garden but
it's
the class was really keen on this as
plants as medicine and knowing how um
how important they've been for millennia
for people so um
we do have plans to interpret the garden
and talk about their uses and in
medicinal way i don't believe there will
be any prescription as part of it but
just to say that this plant
being around this plant smelling this
plant this this type of thing and it may
what we do in the herb garden is we we
say how it's been used but we don't say
how to use it because you know there's a
fine like with a lot of these plants
it's a fine line between with dosage and
dosage is so important so
um
part of that
uh
database that daniel came up with is is
you know if any of those have any dosage
like if they straddle that line of like
if you take this and there's too many
like then we have a problem so we talked
a lot with cornell health about this and
the and the name of the garden as and
the class but in the end they they
really liked the medicinal garden title
and this is being sponsored by the class
of 1971 i should mention
so yeah so that interpretation is that's
part it'll come in
the garden will be installed but the
interpretation will follow
if anyone online has questions
today do they unmute and ask
absolutely this is sort of
a friendly suggestion on your ladder
i've often seen sore ladders similar to
that but what yours didn't have that a
lot of them have and that's
step one
is building trust and
uh and sort of that relationship
where people can be a little bit
vulnerable and risky for the first step
as opposed to jumping right in
to learning and doing things
so maybe just think about and maybe that
was borrowed from them it was barred
from them but i i've seen that um in a
lot of the leadership training that i've
had and gone through
part of the way
i see that we do that
is as they are all participants and and
part of the the team building that's
happening once they're all together is
to do things that aren't just about
project focus i mean some of it is just
about having fun together and building
community together and that in that
community building you're starting to
develop that sense of trust so that
if you if the student leaders in the
program have to say
you know have a difficult conversation
with someone there is some rapport there
already and there's a safe space to have
that kind of conversation
um and we we had to have one over the
course of the semester you know so it's
not uncommon even at this early stage
um and i think that
part of the way we had done enough team
building and
fun collaborative trying to build space
for that that it it was um it actually
was a really
good conversation and helped move
everybody in the right direction
yeah i'm sure you do it
but putting it into the model no i think
that's great
and it's the foundation for everything
else you do
i like that
well thank you thanks for being here
today
yeah i invite you all to come down and
enjoy everything is in bloom so um
i know you get to see it on campus but
it's a little different down the hill so
come on down oh yes sorry i do have one
question yes it's true that um there are
jumping worms in the bed some of the
beds and so i wondered how
your teams
are working to like
mitigate that and or make sure that in
the plants that they sell
that
you know those aren't contaminated no
that's a great question we do have that
problem
um
so for a lot of the plant material that
they
they purchase and then they grow up
that's fresh media that they're being
that they're used and so when they go
out it's not even hasn't been touched
but one of the projects that i didn't
share that they're working on over the
summer is they're dividing a lot of our
day lilies so we and they're going to
have in june or july i think it's july
if you're here and you're interested in
daylilies they've divided
almost all of the ones that are in our
collection and we'll be having a daylily
sale as part of that to address the
problem that you're talking about and
any other pests that might come along as
hitchhikers on that is they're cleaning
all the roots off and then they they use
fresh material to put that in
so that's one of the ways that they do
it
and i think that they do that with
anything that will come out of our
collections like out of the soil in
general
so but it's a good question i'll follow
up and make sure and ask
okay
thanks everybody
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu